el puente internacional Paso del norte
uno de los lugares culmen para miles de
migrantes que sueñan con cruzar hacia
territorio estadounidense miles lo han
hecho llegan hasta el Paso Texas desde
Ciudad Juárez Pero allí son aprendidos
por la patrulla fronteriza cuando no
pueden demostrar un estatus migratorio
legal son inmediatamente
deportados expulsados por otro puente el
puente libre quedando en territorio
mexicano en una suerte de Limbo aquí en
Ciudad Juárez
sí me pongo nerviosa porque dicen que
cuando se quite el título 42 se va a
activar el 8 que es un poco más fuerte
pero mientras tenga la esperanza en la
aplicación creo que
acabamos a estar el tiempo que sea
necesario
hasta que la página algún momento nos
diga Bueno ya es tu momento Oye la
verdad que no ninguno de esos artículos
lo entiendo no es un zaperoco que no
alguien te dice una y la otra persona
viene y te dice otra cosa Este es el
tipo de hoteles o edificios desocupados
en Ciudad Juárez que muchos de los
migrantes que han llegado hasta aquí han
decidido ocupar una situación un
panorama que ha sido tolerado por parte
del gobierno de Chihuahua pero no en
todas las ocasiones sobre todo
acercándonos al fin del título 42 cuando
se han denunciado que se han realizado
redadas nocturnas
de anoche como a las 7 de la noche
empezaron lo que fueron operativos de
migración mexicana sí junto con la
policía y el ejército sí tratando de una
manera muy muy muy drástica si me
entiende Entonces los empezaron a llevar
a arrestar para llevarnos no sé las
personas que se llevaron o no sé para
dónde se la llevarían sí muchos de los
migrantes que por semanas han
permanecido aquí en Ciudad Juárez sin
resolver su estatus migratorio pudieron
atestiguar cuando se incendió este
centro migratorio el pasado 27 de marzo
en el que murieron 40 migrantes El
recuerdo de aquel incendio y la
incertidumbre de lo que va a pasar con
ellos después del título 42 son factores
que le agregan más tensión a la atención